[Music]  i am just incredibly humble blessed  [Music]  you inspire and you dream i never  imagined that i would get to work with  so many amazing talented people you guys  have elevated me  working in television for a long time  and not being able to see people that  look like me to be able to do a show  like that now says the groundwork that  people want to make more shows like us  is just really special  i'm putting all elements of my life so i  could say this is rooted in authenticity  and they were like okay green light  for people of color in this industry the  fear of failure is so real because we  don't get that many  show has been opportunities of the  revolution  the way you showcase our beautiful black  full humanity is part of the revolution  we all owe so much to you it's rare to  go to work every day and love every  single person we've had on our  production  it's all you could dream for let's go  and reach to the sky baby  [Music]  you